so michael you've played a few roles
where you're a woman
in the scene or or on stage what's that
like
what's your approach to it i'm sure each
one of those is different
yeah i'm trying to because i i'm trying
to think if there's more i know i've
played
three women for sure the very first show
i did
um was a shakespeare show the very first
equity uh union show i did
was a shakespeare show um and so i
played nell the kitchen wench
um the director of that called up my
parents and
made sure it was okay i was in a dress
cause i was only 17 i think
so he was just making sure that that
wouldn't offend them or anything
i was doing rocky horror at the time so
they were like it's fine
he's already wearing mascara in the show
he's in right now so
go for it um and that lady i would
yeah that lady wasn't i didn't have to
get at the core of playing a lady i was
i was yelling a comedic shakespearean
line and chasing a guy around the stage
trying to kiss him
you know um i would say the
the female role that i've played that
was the most
uh encompassing in really trying to get
into the psyche of a lady
um was hairspray
i got to play the mom edna in hairspray
at the iverton playhouse
it was the same uh the same year
spider-man came out
because i actually came out for the
premiere and i had to fly out the next
morning because i had a tech rehearsal
in connecticut
so um yeah that one was cool
because so you're playing she's a woman
it's not you're not playing a gay man
she's she's a woman with motherly
instincts
who just loves her daughter more than
life itself
and wants to see her succeed you know so
she has that very maternal like
i will do anything for my baby kind of
thing you know
um but what's fun about that role
is you play those maternal instincts you
play that woman
but through the voice and body of a man
you know
this is this was how my edna talked
i mean i'm i may have camped it up a
little bit you know she may have gotten
a little harvey fierstein on some lines
but it was
it really adds to the comedy of that
role when you have
these very delicate and loving
maternal instincts being delivered in a
gruff voice you know
saying things i'm trying to think of uh
the lines where he's just like oh my
baby
you know like just anything like that is
is
is funny coming from a guy when it has
that heart behind it
and in the film was that played by
divine in the film it was divine
and then uh john travolta in the new
movie and then uh
harvey fierstein did it most famously on
stage
uh i think he won the tony for it but
yeah did you watch the original
when you i had seen the original company
on broadway i saw harvey fierstein do it
there
i had seen um the original
yeah i guess i'd seen all three of them
i was trying to think because i know i
saw the john travolta one
and i saw the i did see the original
movie yeah but
i would say if i was influenced
by any previous performances it was for
sure harvey fierstein
um i think his yeah my performance was
probably most closely to him but i
i like to think i'd you know did my own
thing with
it right so it sounds like it just
depends on the role like from a mrs
doubtfire
to you know something that it just
depends on who the person is as that
woman yeah i mean i guess
that's one of the things with any role
that
you play is you can't really judge them
because as soon as you say
this is a bad person or this is a
a silly person or this then
you're only attacking them from you're
only thinking about that character from
that one aspect of it you know um
rather than just this is a person
you know and just trying to
it's it's again with like playing at
something rather than
playing something you know does that
does that make sense or yeah but i'd
like to like to hear more about it
yeah playing at something so what was
what was the original question
because i feel like i rambled again
there my question's a little vague i
realize that but i mean what what is it
like to play a woman but i guess you're
right it depends because there's so many
different types of men
and women so it depends you're playing
one a very strong
motherly figure who's very particular of
her daughter versus i know you played
what was it
um in one of marty's short films of
transvestite
shopaholic yeah yeah that was in a short
film uh
uh written by marty lang for the kinetic
film
industry training program it's a
mouthful
um but yeah that was called time's up
and i played a uh
a transvestite who um had a shopping
addiction
yeah um yeah i mean
playing a woman role
i don't approach any differently than
playing any
role because every
every role is different you know so
just grouping the women roles together
all three that i've played have been
totally different from each other you
know
so i guess i approached each one a
different way
sure i know that my edna in hairspray
was was uh very heavily inspired by my
mother
um because i see a lot of similarities
between them you know she's a very
you know mama bear who will protect her
young you know and so i took a lot of
inspiration
from her for that um
with the shakespeare one i i don't even
think i
that that was i was set 16 17 i
i didn't know how to dive into a role
and get it
i was just screaming in a silly voice
for that one you know
um but then for the for the transvestite
role
um that one was actually that
performance was helped a lot by the
director
uh richard dobbs because i came into
that one thinking
okay this is a the the comedic relief in
this
so i'm gonna camp her up she's a
so i'm gonna
you know and he was like no just just
play it
just he was like i don't i don't want
any
just say the line he was like just
because what are
those lines are um i think
uh uh
he said oh i'd say i can't stop shopping
and he says uh i think you have a
problem and i say i know
and he says do you know what it is and i
just say shoes
and so that's originally the first
couple takes i was like
shoes like you know really camping it up
and then we got to the point where he
was like you're a person
your problem you truly believe is shoes
deliver with the urgency of saying you
know what your problem is
ocd or you know what your problem is
diabetes
say it like it like shoes is your
disease
and getting at it from that more
realistic side of it
rather than campy i think made it ten
times funnier
you know right instead of being that
again that heightened version yeah
you're just
yeah you're being real interesting and i
think that aids in
all comedy like acting wise you have to
approach that all
from the the side of truth rather than
playing at the joke you play the moment
you know rather than saying okay this is
where the punch line is and so i need to
land that
you just say this is what the moment is
this is
what you know what he's feeling in that
moment
rather than here's the joke i'm
delivering
you know